I'm John Strohmeyer and I'm a Troop Order of the Arrow
Representative Advisor with Troop 55 in Houston, Texas.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast
is sponsored by backers like me,
And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
["Scoutmaster"]
One of my favorite authors is. this quote is attributed to him,
And I'm talking about Mark Twain.
He probably didn't actually say it.
If you're a Mark Twain fan, it really does sound like him.
But here is what he said,
And I think this is a great thing for fathers everywhere
to know.
He said: when I was a boy of 14, my father was so ignorant
I could hardly stand to have the old man around.
But when I got to be 21,, I was astonished
at how much the old man had learned in seven years.
["Scoutmaster"].
It's called the Twain effect.
So if you're the father, or the mother, indeed- of a 14-year-old-
and yeah, they don't
Just wait,
It'll happen-
The Twain effect works.
Hey, this is podcast number 316..
Hey,
["Scoutmaster"].
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's see, looking in the mailbag.
Actually, this came from one of the chats that we have,
And every Tuesday and Wednesday morning,
just about every Tuesday and Wednesday morning,
I'll be at scoutmastercgcom
And we'll have a live chat
And a lot of people show up and we
discuss all kinds of things, sometimes really important things,
And sometimes we just talk about the weather,
where we went camping or something like that.
So look at the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed
And watch for an announcement that the live chat is happening
on Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Come along and join us.
But on the live chat this past week
I heard from a parent and a committee member and a mom.
She signed on and she said: our scoutmaster
has heard that he can hold up rank advancement at a Scoutmaster
conference for not showing scout spirit.
I understand the concept, I think,
but I wonder how this should be done and communicated
to a scout that's excited about moving up in rank
and who has met all the requirements.
And my reply was: you know,
that's really not quite how it works.
A scoutmaster conference is just that: a conference.
A scout does not pass or fail a conference.
They just sit down with the scoutmaster and they have a talk.
And as for the requirement to demonstrate scout spirit
by living the scout oath and law,
well, that's not really a pass or fail
kind of a requirement, is it?
I never considered it to be one,
And it's not something that a scoutmaster evaluates
using their own judgment. because what is the requirement?
Demonstrate scout spirit by living the scout oath
and law. and the scout in the earlier rank
shares four points of the scout law.
It gives examples how they have been living the ideals
in those four points. right,
I don't see that as being a pass fail thing.
I think it's a wonderful conversation to have with a scout
and maybe- yeah, maybe- you encourage them to do more
or you congratulate them on doing just a marvelous job with it,
But I can't see failing that requirement.
I don't know how you would do that.
Then they replied: well, if a scoutmaster has a scout
he thinks is moving too fast through the ranks
or is having behavior issues
or whom the scoutmaster considers to be immature,
he should not be using the scout spirit excuse
to slow them down. then-
And my reply was yes, that's absolutely the point.
So the resource that you wanna look at to explain this
is the Guide to Advancement,
where it talks about scoutmaster conferences,
and I will have a link to that resource
in the podcast notes for you.
And I wanna challenge a couple of other things
that you said here.
It's impossible for a scout to move too fast
through the requirements.
There's no reference to age or maturity
in any of the rank requirements.
The only time we see age mentioned
is when a boy joins a scout troop.
So that's already all been taken care of
And I would probably suggest that you don't try
to argue with the scoutmaster
because they don't understand what they're doing.
I would think about very seriously
just finding another troop
where the scoutmaster understands scouting,
because the one that you're working with doesn't.
Now the conversation went on from there
and there were other things that kind of pointed out
that this particular scoutmaster
really had very little idea of what their job was.
The people in the position to make any kind of change
within a scout troop,
that's the committee chair
and the charter organization representative.
If they're not going to tell the scoutmaster,
who does not understand their work,
what changes they need to make,
then I think it's just time to find a new troop.
It's not that big a deal.
It seems like a very big deal until you're done
and you found a new troop,
because I hear from people who've done that
and it works out.
There's no reason to subject your children.
I understand that something like that's gonna be
a little upsetting.
it's gonna be a bit of a challenge,
but I hear from people who go ahead and change troops
and then they find out that that was a very good idea.
I've had lots of scouts over the years
who have come to our troop from a different troop
because it just wasn't working for them,
and I've had some of my scouts
our troop doesn't quite work for them
and they go to another troop.
That's fine,
I have no problem with that.
That's just kind of an encapsulated version
of a discussion that we had on the chat this past week.
Come and join us on Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
We have a great time.
Lots of frequent flyers check in.
The only person that was new who checked in this week
was the person who asked me the question
I've been talking about,
and they didn't really share where they were from
or anything like that.
But come and check us out on the chat.
Now, before I move on to bigger and better things,
I need to ask you a favor.
If you're a regular reader and listener
and the resources that I've created help you,
you can return the favor.
You can support scoutmastercgcom
by making a one-time payment
and become a scoutmastercgcom backer,
And that's a very simple thing to do,
or you can make a ongoing subscription payment
of $5 or more a month
through something called Patreon, P-A-T-R-E-O-N,
And there are special premiums
for people who become patrons and backers.
You can learn more about those
by going to scoutmastercgcom. right there
at the top of the page over on the right,
There's a link that says support
and that'll tell you about being a backer.
There's a link that says Patreon
That'll take you to my Patreon page
and explain all of that.
That's what I need you to do for me this week.
Just check the two of those out,
see which one works for you.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank
Dan and Rose Gardner-Bowler-
And Dan and Rose, I had your first names last week,
but I found your last names this week-
And also Dan Stroh,
who became backers since last week's podcast.
Thanks very much, folks.
Become a patron or a backer this week.
I'll make sure to thank you personally
in next week's podcast.
And one other thing I wanted to tell you:
later on this week
I'll be recording an interview with the author
of the new troop leader guide,
both volume one and volume two.
Volume two is due to be out this coming month
And I'm gonna be recording an interview
with the author, Mark Ray.
Later on this week
my pal Walter Underwood's gonna join me.
I have an advanced copy of volume two
and I've looked at it and you're gonna like it.
It's gonna be a key resource for scouts.
I'm looking forward to sharing that interview with you.
Hopefully it'll be out next week's podcast,
But on this week's podcast
we're gonna dust off a recurring feature
called Scout Mastership in Seven Minutes or Less
And, as is usual,
we're probably gonna go a little more than seven minutes.
And my theme
for this installment of Scout Mastership
in Seven Minutes or Less-
scouting is something for scouts to discover.
So that's gonna take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scouts Mastership in Seven Minutes or Less.
So the big idea here is that scouting
is something for scouts to discover.
One of the perennial things that we discuss is leadership.
Leadership is one of those magic scouting words
we think we understand,
but few of us really appreciate the length and breadth
of just what that magic word implies
when we start applying it to scouting.
So today I wanna talk about leadership
as something that scouts get to discover for themselves.
I wanna see if I can get you to come along
and really think about this, really examine this idea.
Now, one of the things I frequently hear from scouters
is that our youth leaders just don't do
what they're supposed to do.
They don't seem to have any initiative,
And what I hear when somebody says that,
what they're telling me is that their scouts
don't seem to care about the expectations
that adults have set for them.
So what these scouters have usually done
is they have set themselves up as the leader,
as the ones who approve or disapprove of what scouts do.
In other words, they have reserved
all of the actual authority and power to themselves.
They're waiting for the scouts
in some way to prove themselves
And after one or two tries
and the scouts don't respond as the adults want them to,
they usually don't try it again.
They oh no, we tried that a couple of times
and it really didn't work.
They don't like the way the scouts responded,
So they stop trying that
and they end up just taking over
and doing everything for the scouts.
I mean, a lot of us have the idea
that adults in scouting hold all the cards
and deal them out to the scouts as they see fit.
but that's really not scouting at all
And you aren't getting the whole idea of leadership
if you see yourself that way,
And where this gets complicated is: yes,
you are the adult in the equation
and you do have all the authority,
because you're there to referee
and make sure the things don't go wrong,
And naturally, we wouldn't just sit back
and watch young people do untoward or dangerous things-
They are, after all, in our care-
But, in another sense, you are not the authority.
You are not the person who must be placated
or pleased or served by what your scouts do.
That's not the kind of leadership your scouts want or need.
You aren't the personification of excellence
and the keeper of standards.
All of that work has already been done for you.
It was all established, written down and described
for many years, before you even showed up.
What I need you to do, as the adult in the equation,
is to consider yourself serving the things that were here
before you got on the scene.
You don't personify those things.
You're serving those things.
You're serving the program.
So what is this other entity?
What is this program?
Well, it's scouting itself,
A process, a field of play.
You didn't invent it,
You didn't create it.
Hopefully, though, what you're doing
is striving to understand it.
So I'm going to offer this analogy
And before we go down the analogy trail,
which is an analogy itself,
I need to point out three things. okay,
This is a really complicated analogy.
That's the first thing,
And you may have to go back and listen again.
Hopefully I'll get it in one try for you, okay.
The second thing I need to tell you
is you will discover in listening to this,
that I am actually doing the antithesis
of the point of the analogy
and explaining it the way that I am.
And third, and probably most importantly,
this is an analogy
which is hopefully a useful tool
to simplify the explanation of complex concepts.
And because it is an analogy,
it, like all analogies, breaks down at some point.
So don't go crazy with it, okay,
Don't try and read more into it.
It's just an analogy,
It's just an idea to help explain a complex concept,
All right. so here it is, right
Now. imagine you go off on a hike
and you discover an ancient pre-Columbian
Mesoamerican steppe pyramid in the forest.
Everybody's probably seen a picture
of exactly what I'm talking about,
And down in Central and South America
there are these incredible Mesoamerican steppe pyramids,
And so picture that in your mind.
You just break into a clearing and there it is.
Wouldn't that be something?
You're out hiking and you stumble
on this terrific structure that nobody knows about,
And as you approach it,
you see all kinds of symbols
have been carved into the stones.
So you do what anybody would do, right?
You climb all over the pyramid.
you look at the symbols,
you get to the top-
Wow, you can see a long way from the top.
And then you devote yourself to studying this discovery
and learn to understand the symbols.
And there's a great message in those symbols
that just changes your entire life.
That's exciting, isn't it?
Wow? but for the sake of this analogy,
that's what's happened to you.
You've stumbled on this great discovery.
Now you definitely want to share this with other people.
So at some point
you get a bunch of young people together
and you take them down the trail,
and when they first see the pyramid,
they're just stunned
And they immediately do what any young person would do:
They run towards it.
What fun, they're gonna climb it.
They want to play on it.
It's just something they've never seen before in their lives.
But you say: stop, stop, wait.
I want to explain what this whole thing means.
I want to explain all the symbols.
So over the next few hours.
you walk them around your discovery
and explain the symbols to them.
Now, at first they listen,
But, you know, within a few minutes
the youngest one raises their hand at one point
and asks how long this is gonna take.
And even the most interested young people
are starting to get a little antsy.
Now you've been in a situation like that, right,
And how do you react?
Well, I don't know about you,
but it would make me a little upset,
Don't they understand how important it is
to know what the symbols mean?
I mean, after all, it changed my life
And I'm. you know
you guys just need to stand here and listen
Because I'm telling you really important stuff.
So you have a little edge of resentment, right,
And after a while
you're spending as much time keeping everyone in order
as you are explaining,
And you may even have to raise your voice a couple of times.
Once you've done that-
because the young people that you're with
have been trained to listen to adults-
they finally just say, okay,
well, this isn't gonna be any fun,
but I'll give it and listen.
We'll just wait this adult out
because they've got to run out of steam sometime.
So you remember being a kid and thinking that you know,
oh, school can't last forever.
It has to be over at 345..
This old man has to stop talking sometime.
I'll wait him out and then we'll do fun stuff.
So anyway, it starts to get dark.
You've got to head back
and you're only halfway through your talk
And dang it. you think
if these kids would just listen- you know,
if they would just do what I say and listen-
we'd be much farther along
and they would understand this wonderful discovery
a lot better.
So you go back and you say, okay,
meet me here tomorrow morning and we'll go out
and I'll finish my talk.
And next morning
about half as many young people show up.
and geez, you think
I guess the other ones just don't understand
how important this is.
I have this incredible gift to share with them.
So you know it's their loss.
I'll take the ones that showed up. okay, fine.
And the second day ends up going a lot like the first.
as you march them around, describing all the symbols
in detail. you finish with the symbols
at the base of the pyramid
and now you're climbing up to the first step.
but oh, it gets dark again. it's time to go home.
And the third morning you go back
and there's only one or two young people who show up,
and it's really disheartening.
So what happens next?
Well, maybe you go to the parents of all the young
people and you tell them how important this is.
They should make their children do this
because they need to learn what you have to offer them,
because the secrets you've learned from the pyramid
are really important to their children's success
later in life.
And you'd probably end up with bigger crowds that way.
but it would be different, because you know,
my parents made me come here and do this
and get to the point so that it can be over
as soon as possible.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. the symbols:
Yeah, yeah, yeah, important, right,
Yeah, it would be a totally different thing, wouldn't it?
Now, maybe, instead of that, you get resentful
and you say: you know, these dang kids
just can't appreciate what I'm trying to do for them.
They're noisy, undisciplined rascals
and I'm gonna create rules and regulations
that they have to abide by
before they can go with me again.
That's how I became the person that I am,
because adults did that to me.
so that's what I'm gonna do to them.
We're gonna have a little toughness here,
We're gonna give them some backbone
and maybe, instead of those first two options,
you take a third option and you sit down
and you get kind of real with yourself
and you say: maybe it's not the young people
who are the problem here,
Maybe that's how I'm going about this.
So you start thinking.
So you start thinking: what was so motivating
and exciting about my discovery, right?
Well, the first time you stepped into the clearing
and you saw the pyramid- wow,
That was a moment that you'll never forget.
And the first time you got to the top of the pyramid
and looked around over the tops of the trees,
that was really something.
Then, when you studied and understood
the symbols on the pyramid, that was a lot of work
and you nearly gave up a couple of times,
but you're glad you kept at it,
because the message was just an absolute life changer.
So as you're thinking about this, a light comes on.
Now you know what you need to do.
Next morning. you get a big group of young people together
and you hike out to the pyramid
And, of course, along the way,
they're saying: are we there yet?
Where are we going?
What are you doing?
And you just say: well, follow along a little further.
We're almost there.
And just before you break through the forest
into the clearing. you stop and you say,
okay, it's just a little ways. now you go ahead
And the young people pass you by
and you hear them as they step out of the forest
into the clearing.
Wow, will you look at that?
Then they shout and they're happy
and you hear the sound of running feet.
And when you get into the clearing,
the young people are climbing all over the pyramid.
They're shouting and playing
And of course, somebody is the first one to get to the top
and all the others have to get to the top
and look around.
They're just as excited as you were
the day you discovered it.
So you set up the chair that you brought along
and you sit down and you watch them.
And you see them going over on that right-hand side,
where it's a real long drop,
and you say, hey, watch out there.
And they step back from the edge
and you just keep a watchful eye on them
to make sure they don't injure themselves
or mess up the pyramid in some way or something.
And after they've played and climbed around
on it a couple of hours,
a few young people come over to where you're sitting
and they say, hey, what does that panther
on the pyramid mean.
What is that?
And you look at them and you say,
well, what do you think it means?
Did you see any other symbols on the pyramid?
And you have a little discussion
about what they think it means.
and they're getting close.
They almost understand that particular symbol
and in the way it works with all the other ones.
but you're not gonna tell them right away.
You want them to have the joy
of figuring it out for themselves.
So day after day
you bring this group of young people
to this wonderful pyramid that you found.
The younger ones are happy to climb around and play.
Some of the older ones have started to interpret
the basic symbols and you can tell it won't be long
before they understand and they know what you know,
And indeed before too long.
the young people really don't need you around much anymore.
They understand where the dangerous spots are
and everything, and they understand
what the symbols mean and how it all works
and they know their way around the pyramid
and then delight in helping others discover it.
So every morning the crowd's getting a little bigger
because they're telling their friends about it.
So I'm gonna stop before the analogy
begins to break down. but did you get it?
Does the analogy work for you?
Of course the pyramid is scouting:
A discovery that you share with young people,
not by explaining it to them,
but through their own sense of inquisitiveness and discovery.
Now let's loop back to where we began.
We began with the idea of leadership.
Scouting belongs to scouts
who lead themselves through the scouting experience right.
It does not belong to adults.
Scouters are not the chief executive officers.
They are mentors and enablers.
Scouting is not a useful set of skills we need to teach
or object lessons we have to explain.
It is a unique path of discovery with opportunities
to learn those skills and those object lessons
and experience growth.
Scouting is not a program we prepare and present to scouts.
It is a program based on the magic of discovery
and things that they learn for themselves
and then they're able to turn around
and share with others.
So for our scouts- and I'm speaking of our scouts
of every age, from joeys and beavers to cubs,
and ventures and rovers-
it's about discovering scouting for yourself,
under your own steam, under your own leadership,
exercised in correspondence with your age and your abilities.
And rather than explaining exactly how that works
across all ages and abilities,
let me refer you to a post I wrote earlier this year
called Every Scout is a Leader,
And I'll have a link to that post in the podcast notes.
In that post I lay out four types of leadership
Basically. first, you lead yourself.
Second, you follow cooperatively.
Third, you help your fellow scouts.
And fourth, you shape the directions
and plans of your patrol and troop.
Now you really can't skip any of those steps,
so you have to start where your scouts are.
And I'm not going to say
that adults aren't leaders in scouting,
because we definitely are.
It's just the kind of leaders that we need to be.
We need to be responsive leaders.
Our response and our level of involvement
in what is happening needs to correspond
with the growing abilities of our scouts.
You can't just decide.
if you're in a scout troop, for example,
you can't just decide, okay,
we're going to be youth led now,
and throw a switch and walk away.
It's not instantaneous.
Youth leadership is not throwing a switch.
It's more like planting a seed. okay,
And I know more analogies, right,
Okay, just bear with me.
If we throw a light switch and the light
doesn't come on right away, we get impatient.
But if we plant a seed and it doesn't sprout
in 10 seconds, well, we aren't surprised.
We know that this sort of thing takes time.
You can't plant a seed and go boop
and the next minute have an oak tree right.
It takes some time.
So what's in that seed that causes it to grow?
There's tremendous potential in there,
but it has to have the right environment
And the right environment. in scouting,
the mysterious process at the heart of it all
is discovery.
So back to the big analogy. it's back to the pyramid.
You're leading because you're getting them there right.
You're getting them to the opportunities.
You don't really create the opportunities quite so much
as scouting itself creates the opportunities.
And you're keeping an eye on things
because, yes, the scouts are in our care,
So we have to have that authority to keep an eye on things,
make sure they're not doing untoward or dangerous things,
but we bring them to this place
of opportunity and discovery,
And that's what scouting really is.
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this.
I want you to get in touch with me this week.
It's real easy
And I'm gonna tell you how to do it in just a moment.
Well, thank you for listening to this 316th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Go to scoutmastercgcom, where you can read the blog
and you can subscribe to updates by email.
And you know a lot of folks follow us on social media-
13,000 folks like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
There's a chorus of tweeters on Twitter.
Plenty of people peruse the Pultritudinous pictures
we proffer publicly on Pinterest
And you can watch us at Scoutmastercg on YouTube.
But if you can't face Facebook and Twitter
makes you bitter and you have no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube,
well, that's all right, Bunky,
Don't worry about that.
Just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom,
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if none of that works for you,
the next time you're out camping,
gather your fellow scouters around a magic mirror
and repeat Scoutmaster CG three times in unison
And I will appear and answer all of your questions.
Now, by this time it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor they endorse or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any scouting organization for that matter.
No, it is only me talking into a microphone
and trying to lend a hand to my fellow scouters
and having a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.